thank you
all right looks like we're now live for
the Hegel party uh I see there's already
some people here I'm sure we're going to
be joined by others in a bit and what I
had planned for this is uh fairly
unstructured I'm going to talk about
the Inception and motive for the half
hour Hegel project some of the
issues we ran into over the years
how we dealt with those what's coming up
next
um not for half hour Hegel but for
similar kinds of projects and
maybe you know some other things that
occur to me along the way I see a few
people already commenting feel free to
comment or leave questions and I will
try to get to as many of those as I can
Zeitgeist has kind of a funny one I can
feel the power of Hegel coming inside me
um I mean I don't know what the power of
Hagel would be at this point in time
he's been
dead and gone for not quite two
centuries but getting on there although
you know there's there's we could say
that there's something contained in his
works right that is coming through and
maybe that might be a interesting
broader topic because it's not just
about Hegel but about what we get out of
reading in general including what what
Hegel thinks that we get out of studying
other philosophers
so you know why don't I start by talking
about why I did the project in the first
place and what a crazy thing it was to
commit to doing I'm glad we finally got
it to to the end so about nine and a
half years ago
actually I gotta back up a little bit
further about 10 years ago I had
um you know people asking me as my
YouTube videos of my class sessions at
Marist College were becoming quite
popular
um there were people who were saying can
you do videos on this person or this
person or this person
and eventually I decided you know what I
need to do is actually like pull people
and and see what they they want done and
interestingly so Jean-Paul sart was a
big favorite Martin Heidegger another
big favorite uh you know Hegel was a
third and then the other one that people
were big on at the time that I've never
done any videos on Herbert marcusa who I
was kind of a fan of back in
undergraduate and early graduate school
but haven't done much with since other
than being in a short reading group on
on one-dimensional man
and so you know I started doing this
existentialist series and you might have
seen some of the videos for that quite a
few on on
you know uh
sart
Iger Kierkegaard nature Gabriel Marcel
chest off people like that and I figured
well that's got the start and Heidegger
covered now what should I do for Hegel
and I thought you know I can't do quite
the same thing as I'm doing say for
Nietzsche's birth of tragedy where I'm
like going through portions of it in an
hour-long video and doing a lot of
summarizing that's not gonna work for
say hegel's phenomenology of Spirit and
the phenomenology of spirit is the text
that I thought of doing because it's
probably the most popular at this point
in time although I should mention that
in the 19th century the phenomenology
was not the most widely read it was
other works by by Hegel so
um
I I thought okay I'm going to do the
phenomenology how can I do this well how
can I do something that isn't going to
be just
you know
surface level so I thought okay I got to
do line by line commentary what we call
a close reading and not leave anything
out because it's tempting when you get
to difficult parts of a work to say yeah
you could say something about this but
I'm going to skip over it and then jump
to another part and I thought that's
kind of a cop-out I don't want to do
that with Hegel and and I did have the
background in Hegel to be able to do it
I almost wrote my dissertation on uh
Hegel and Maurice Blondell I had to take
a preliminary exam as special thinker on
Hagel one of the four exams that I had
to do before I could qualify to do my
dissertation and that involved
essentially memorizing all the
dialectics of the phenomenology and some
some you know reading around in the
science of logic and a few other texts
so I had the chops to do it I'm not the
best Hegel scholar out there in part
because I do a lot of different things
and so you know I don't have the
single-mindedness of people who
concentrate primarily on Hegel or who
may have a wider range but you know
still spend more time with Hegel and
less time doing undergraduate teaching
people who get to like specialize and
just teach graduate students but nobody
else is doing videos so I thought all
right how should I do this and then I
thought about the time frame should I do
it in like hour-long videos and I'd
already started experimenting with these
core concept videos that are shorter and
then I was like
I don't want to do hour long videos I
think it'd be better if they're about
half an hour long right
so how should I do this well I'll have a
little musical intro I'll use PowerPoint
to make some slides
um people should actually read the text
so I'll start out with some you know
passages from the text and then I'll uh
comment on it in front of my chalkboard
right and after a while you know I get
through the preface which is pretty long
and that I was like you know I need to
do something with a different background
maybe and so I started experimenting
with these sorts of things if you've
watched the series you see that
obviously like the video quality has
improved over time as I moved from a
flip cam to uh another uh camera a Hero
GoPro and then to another Hero GoPro
that I have now sound quality has
improved once I started using a mic but
you know it's all understandable I hope
and hopefully these videos will be
around as a resource for a number of
years Barbara says in nine years
technology itself improved over time
that's quite true you know like the hero
camera's gotten better but I also
um you know I I started out low Tech I
I've never been a video channel that
does high production stuff because I
think that
um people spend a lot of time and money
on Glitz and not enough on actual
content and you know I mean think about
here's a metaphor for you here's my my
book and people have noted oh it's
getting tattered and worn and stuff like
that yeah but the words are still there
and until those words are lost it's you
know it's decent enough for for me to
use so
um
so anyway back to like the Inception of
it so I started filming and then I was
like all right this is going along
pretty good and eventually I decided to
create a patreon for it I did that
before I did my regular patreon by the
way the half hour Hegel patreon not not
right now but in in the future is going
to be going away and rolling into my
regular patreon because the project is
is finished and I I thank all the people
who have helped me out along the way not
only financially but in terms of
encouragement and sharing the videos and
talking up the series and stuff like
that so you know that's that's really
quite great and
um you know I kept plowing away at it
and there have been times when I've had
to put it kind of on hold because of
either health issues or being overloaded
with work you know there have been
semesters where I've taught got seven
classes at different institutions and
actually turned some classes down so all
of these other things can kind of get in
the way and you know shooting videos on
Hegel is is not the easiest thing
compared to some of the other thinkers
I've I've had times where I put things
on the chalkboard got ready to present
you know I'm rereading the paragraph and
I get in front of the chalkboard I'm all
dressed up as usual and then I'm like oh
I can't do it today I I I don't I can't
follow the train of thought so then I
had to put it on on hold and try the
next day right so all right so that's
that's probably enough about the start
let's let's look at the questions and
comments and then I'll I'll uh get into
some other things
um
so a lot of congratulations thanks for
that uh that's a good one by Phyllis
Phyllis philosophical
cultist the absolute Ideal Party that's
a great joke
um
people have got questions or suggestions
about who to talk I'm going to do next
I'll I'll talk about that in just a bit
um Scotty says any interest in
interpreting or reviewing some more
Niche philosophers such as Levi Nasser
to lose I've actually shot videos on to
lose just got to search in the channel
I'm not a huge fan of loving us
um in part because the lebanosians that
I encountered in grad school left such a
bad taste in my mouth because they're
constantly talking about the other and
its face and how we're betraying it and
theory is all hypocrisy and I understand
that loving us is more than that but
sometimes you know you you look at the
the interpreters and followers and you
can be like yeah not really my scene
there you know
um
France is the absolute has been attained
you know according to Hegel yeah by the
end of the book but whether that's
really the case or not we have to think
that through
um
Lotus van congrats on fully completing
the system of German idealism well
you know
we haven't we haven't done that
um the phenomenology isn't the totality
of hegel's system and there's a lot of
discussion and disagreement among Hegel
Scholars about exactly what is the
system what's the relation between for
example the phenomenology of Spirit and
the science of logic which is the next
big book that follows or the
encyclopedia logic or the uh philosophy
of right and you know the general answer
is there's lots of answers and nobody
really knows you know it's it's
something that great philosophers do
find perplexing some people like to get
really schematic with it and draw the
correspondences between the works but
that's all very speculative
um
so you know and
I know that we we treat this
completion of the system of German
idealism is kind of a joke these days
but it was it was kind of a big issue
for people back then I guess and I don't
see that it's all that important now in
part because you know if we're taking
Hegel as a guide obviously history
didn't end there's lots of stuff that
he's left out he's got a very uh
eurocentric perspective when it comes to
world history
um anyway we could go on and on with
that all right so more congratulations
Mark thanks Mark uh glad you're you're
here Joseph says I'm planning on
starting the whole series next year one
a day oh that's that's a cool idea
there's there's more than 365
but I mean that would get you very close
to the end of it I suppose if you really
wanted to get it done in a year you
could double up or something you know
um Benjamin the goatee gets a lot grayer
as it goes on well fortunately not gray
but white you know
um I I haven't I don't have a lot of
gray hairs I have been at least
according to my wife uh Lucky in that
things are going more white than
anything else including you know
eventually the mustache should be all
the way there I have a friend by the way
over in Belgium who's about my age and
has exactly the opposite thing he has a
big beard which is still brown but his
hair on top is completely White
he's sort of like my mirror image all
right uh
okay Ben the Fidelity and production
value of the videos doesn't detract from
all the information you provide in it I
mean yeah that's a good thing you know
you can hear what's being said you can
look at the chalkboard and see what's
what's on it
um and you know you can follow along
with the text and I think people can get
quite a bit out of it occasionally I
misspell words on the chalkboard you
know I'm not the best speller but that
shouldn't like that's not a critical
issue right
um now here's an interesting thing and I
can't read Cyrillic so I I don't know
how to pronounce this person's name but
Professor you're one awesome hegelian so
that's the interesting thing I'm not a
hegelian
um I enjoy Hegel
um I think that he's very valuable to
study and and think about but I'm not
I'm not a hegelian
um I'm an Eclectic I draw upon a number
of different philosophical points of
view much the way that Cicero does so we
describe this as ciceronian eclecticism
and try to wield them together you know
as far as they can be integrated into
something like a uh well thought out
synthesis but and you might say well why
why would you do a series like this if
you're not a hegelian because I'm not
I'm not a team person right I'm not I do
a lot of work with modern stoicism I'm
not on team stoicism you know thinking
that that's like the only thing that
matters or you know they got everything
completely right I I don't have that
that sort of point of view about Hegel
either I think he's great but I think
that there's a lot of things that he got
wrong even in his own time but that's
okay I think that about Hobbs and
Descartes and Hume and other people who
I teach as well
all right uh Evans says congratulations
I don't know of any other YouTube
channel that makes philosophy so
accessible without sacrificing the depth
and breadth of the subject matter all
the best to you I mean I know of a few
um fortunately there's others out there
but they're doing different things than
I do right so there's there's good
lectures out there uh Gavin says why did
you decide to use the Miller translation
for the series would you use it again if
you were to go back well because the
Miller translation was the most
up-to-date translation in 2014.
um Pinkard was working on his
translation and you could get drafts
online but his translation didn't
actually come out until
the last few years along with two other
recent translations as well
and there wasn't any point in switching
halfway through the Miller translation
is still widely used
um I think that it'll be around for
quite a while I mean there are some
problems with it I will say that
pinkard's translation is definitely
Superior to Miller's translation in a
number of respects including Fidelity to
the actual German tax but Miller is not
awful you know like some translations
you read and you're like what in the
hell is this I don't remember them
saying anything remotely like this for
example there's some some there's a lot
of translations of Marcus Aurelius out
there that I read through and I'm you
know and people like do quotes of and
I'm like
that ain't what he's saying at all that
doesn't sound like like Marcus and then
I go to the Greek and I see that they've
really botched it up
um Miller's you know Miller's decent
right and he has somebody who's
translated myself in Latin and French to
a lesser extent Greek and German I have
learned to be not only humble myself as
a translator but forgiving of other
people's translation and mistakes or
choices because it's tough
um when you're doing translation
projects I haven't done one for quite a
while but I I have uh some on the back
burner that I want to get to eventually
so
all right
um
let's see here just skipped a little bit
let me see if I can scroll back there's
a lot of comments here so
um
Anthony says it's Quite a feat the
series has been a good investment in my
continuous learning and philosophy
that's that's awesome uh philosophical
Community the White Tower until now
we've been reading Hegel mostly from
Greek books now we're very lucky to
watch This Magnificent video series
being produced by a magnanimous
personality like yo thanks very much
that's that's nice to say
um Alex says I'm in Germany by chance
with my copy of Hagel will keep up the
study that's awesome Snoopy is there any
secondary literature on Hegel you'd
recommend any good Scholars thoughts on
Taylor's Hegel and Hagel and modern
society you know I'm
Taylor's somebody who I've never like
really gotten into that that much
um there's something about the way he
writes that for me I I just find it hard
to like get into him I did a whole video
on self-directed study of Hegel that you
can easily Google there's like uh
secondary text that I recommend in there
so you might check that out
um George McClay says it's good to hear
how you manage to derive the actual
meaning Hegel or other philosophers
originally meant does the interpretation
change over time or is there an
objective interpretation I'd get rid of
that word objective because it's not
useful there
um interpretations do change over time
of different philosophers some
interpretations are crap you know some
are great
um
we don't we don't require everybody they
have like the one objective consensus
interpretation you're never going to
find that anybody who tries to sell you
on that is probably lying to you and uh
you would Pro you would do well to
um you know avoid those sorts of
framings of stuff
Masa Milano says what do you think of
Alexander kojev's impact on how we think
of it contemporarily about hegelian
philosophy specifically Ari the Master
Slave dialectic I don't think that too
many people who
talk about Hagel and the Master Slave
dialectic actually read kojev these days
kojev is an interesting author I do like
his introduction to the reading of Hague
only he's got other books that are worth
checking out as well you may not know
this but because you have you know he
actually became an EU administrator
because he thought that this was like
the development of the dialectic in in
real time uh after World War II so you
know I think he's he's uh interesting
but sort of like when you read Heidegger
to lose you're getting more of them than
you are the original thinker his
contemporary who would be much more
faithful to hago would be of course you
know hip Elite right
um and I would say that hip Elite and
kojav have been about equally
influential
in mid-century to up until like the 80s
and 90s Hegel scholarship
um I think that the Master Slave
dialectic gets made far too much of and
I'll just say two things about that so
here is the book
and see this little portion here that's
the Master Slave dialectic here's the
stuff that came before it here's the
stuff that came after it so clearly the
Master Slave dialectic is not the most
important part of the work it's actually
just a tiny little bit of the
self-consciousness section and nobody
should make such a big deal out of it as
they do uh but I think they find it you
know fascinating and sexy and topical
and all that and then they totally
ignore here's the second thing the fact
that the recognition that we're looking
for doesn't happen through the Master
Slave uh uh dialectic right or the
relations in it but through the
development the long complex development
of culture after that so
you know
I may someday do a
another I've done you know seminars on
the Master Slave dialectic I may do that
again in the future
uh Joseph AGS what philosopher do you
find most helpful for dealing with
mental struggles there is an a
philosopher that I find most useful for
that
um guy thank you for making me
understand Hale you saved my life and
time with your incredible lecture so
thank you very much uh that's that's
nice
um
all right so
Corey says your only team is the Green
Bay Packers that's not even true in NFL
football I am not just a Packers fan I'm
also a Chicago Bears fan I grew up in a
family where we watched both games and
had glassware and you know various other
stuff from both of those uh teams rival
teams so you know that's kind of unusual
I'm also a Colts fan uh from living in
Indiana and having family down there for
quite a while
um all right let's see
ludus what do you think about the way
hagel's used by Marx and in Marxism more
broadly I think Marxism is a hot mess of
people reinterpreting marks in a lot of
different ways arguing with each other
excommunicating each other that's a huge
topic
um and I think that um
you know Mark's
has sort of a reductive and polemical
attitude towards Hegel but Marx is doing
his own thing too right
um new atlantism what do you think Hegel
got wrong I I mean I could do a whole
video about that but I think that one of
the biggest things is obviously history
didn't end with the sort of closure that
he thought it had and so there's
important aspects of the development of
human consciousness that have been left
behind I also think he's a little bit
too unitary too singular in the way that
the complex dialectic goes there's a lot
of things that have been left out of the
process
um in part because Hegel himself has a
lot of presuppositions even though he
denies having them about that
Brooklyn do you like Michael sugray I
don't really watch other people much on
YouTube because who's got the time he
seems a competent person but I don't
watch his his videos you know
um
all right uh
let's see
Sam Prentice I've heard a lot of
criticism of Pinker it is a Hegel
scholar but it's interesting to hear you
say it's outright Superior you're
blurring two different things together
clearly
um one of them is being a scholar which
is writing other things about that
person and another is being a translator
you can be a great translator without
being a great scholar you can be a great
scholar without being a great translator
you can be both at the same time
and here's what you you want to keep in
mind you pick any Hegel scholar and you
are going to find people saying bad
things about them there's no like
there's no like ranking or best you know
best 10 Scholars that that sort of thing
doesn't exist right uh once you start
getting to the level of somebody like
Pinkard
you're in a select few of people who are
pretty damn good at what they do and you
can disagree with them you can say that
they've taken the wrong approach but you
know
I would be hesitant to go toe-to-toe
with with him on Hegel interpretation
right
um
all right uh Guy what's your opinion on
Stephen Holgate I don't really have an
opinion on Stephen Holgate you know
um
philosophical Community what can we say
about Hegel and Plato as political
theorists based on their political
aspirations uh they're very different
from each other there's there's
something you can say
um
jabro what are you reading at the moment
well I am finishing up uh the second
book in n.k jemisin's broken Earth
series The Obelisk gate because I'm
doing that next month I'm reading
actually rereading a lot of stuff from
my classes and uh getting ready for
stoicon so I'm going through stoic text
looking for examples that I want to
discuss with beautiful things you know
all right
um
Pro-Am thanks for all your work it's
been valuable I hope you take some time
to rest and enjoy yourself if you can
unfortunately I can't I've got four
classes this semester going I have a
full load of clients that I'm working
with I have lots of other things and you
know I do my volunteering at the cat
shelter I've got a family life so I'm
still pretty busy maybe around Christmas
time I can take a break all right
um
let me see
John Garrell speaking of interpretation
are you into hermeneutics like diltan
gotimer gotimer yes dilute no Heidegger
yes a rent yes record yes Delta no so
sure I'm into hermeneutics
um
Sam Prentiss I've heard people who do
philosophy in French the English
translation of him don't know who him is
is not very good so can't be sure about
that oh talking about kojev yeah it
could be uh
I don't know
um we'd have to take a look at the the
text and see what it looks like
um the internet do you think there's any
truth in what many hegalians such as
Rory Rory is not a hegelian claim that
most philosophy after Hegel tries very
hard to get out of his Embrace but
always seems to somehow go back to him
no I I don't I don't I mean I think that
some people wind up going back into
Hegel but that's often because he's part
of the conversation but it's not like
everybody it's not like you you know at
least a joke around if you try to get
out of the dialectic you hegel's already
anticipated that well that's not
actually true so
all right uh let's see
okay so so now it's a good time
to address some of the other things that
people are asking about oh here's here's
a good one joao our all hagel's videos
going to be continued to be available
for the public that's what putting them
into YouTube means right they're they're
public they're out there why would I
take them down you know
um so people are
um asking about would you do this one
would you do this one so
um I'm not going to do kant's critique
of pure reason because you know I'm not
as interested in Khan and if I was going
to do any Kant it sure as hell wouldn't
be the first critique which I find much
less interesting than the second
critique and the third critique
um
and I think there's plenty of people out
there already doing great work on on
kant's first critique I will be doing
however a series of core concept videos
that I hope to start shooting tonight on
kant's prologomina to any future
metaphysics which is you know an
introduction to the the critique but I'm
not doing the half hour Hegel series
approach to that uh I'm not going to do
it with Spinoza either because I don't
you know frankly I don't find them as
interesting as I do many other
philosophers I I get that a lot of
people are into him but you know having
studied him for
decades and taught him and you know
taken exams on him I just I don't find
him that interesting I will be doing
something on one of his predecessors
though
um Maurice Blondell you know Max
Montague how would you feel about the
possibility of making half our Maurice
blonde doll videos on action I mean I
think I'd probably do some core concept
videos rather than an entire series uh
blown dial is great but he's rather
obscure and you know these videos take
time for me to do time that I could be
spending uh making a living doing other
things so unless there's like
significant support for it
um probably it's not gonna you know it's
not on the horizon but I do plan to do
some core concept videos probably in the
coming year on Maurice Blondell
um
people want to know about the logic and
by the logic we mean the science of
logic which is much more interesting I
think than the encyclopedia logic
and you know people have always been
saying oh you have to do the science of
logic after this no I don't I can do
whatever text I want to you know
um and science of logic is a pretty cool
work and you know it's it's well worth
somebody doing some work on it but you
know there's already a video series an
extensive video series out there on the
science of logic which you can find on
the
um British Hegel Society YouTube you
just gotta like Google it and I don't
see any reason to replicate that by the
way there's also lectures out there on
kant's critique of pure reason you know
uh Robert Wolfe did a whole wonderful
series on on that you know so there's no
reason for me to reinvent wheels that
other people are already doing
and you know here's another one uh
Aquinas is eternal exploration so Mateo
yeah I thought about doing the so Mom I
mean I probably it's such a long work
I'd probably be doing it the rest of my
life and I'm already doing core concept
videos on the somate logia on selected
Parts you know I just released a set on
the five ways so I've got stuff on some
of the stuff in Prima pars and some of
the stuff in the Prima secunde
and you know I think there's other
people that there's so many people out
there doing Thomas Aquinas that maybe I
don't need to do that you know in in
terms of the half our Hegel Series so
what are my actual plans I've already
done another series like the half hour
Hegel series you may or may not know
about it I did it
well
how many years ago at least five years
ago epictetuses and Caribbean uh half
hour treatment line by line looking at
the Greek you know
I actually created an entire online
class which you can find in the study
with Sadler academy uh doing that but I
I I've decided that the next two texts
I'm going to do are shorter texts and
texts that I think really would benefit
from this one is on the person who I've
published the most on in my career in
that Saint Anselm so I'm going to be
going through the pros logian line by
line paragraph by paragraph in the way
that I've done with this half hour Hegel
series
um I'm using uh Thomas Williams
translation for that which is good
um and then you know going back to the
the Latin of course uh which I've got
you know uh Schmidt and saw that
no Schmitz just Schmidt uh his his
addition of and then after that it's
going to be Rene Descartes meditations
on first philosophy
um that's a work that I think would
definitely benefit from this and there
I'll be looking at you know an English
translation from sort of the standard
version that we use uh and then looking
at the French and Descartes own Latin
you may not know this but Descartes
wrote the meditations in Latin and then
had it translated into French for him
right so
um
then after that I I'm willing to take on
a big book like you know a big thick
book like the phenomenology and the one
that I'm leaning to the most right now
is actually starts being a nothingness
because it's it's a great book it's one
that I cut my teeth on it's probably the
first big philosophy book that I read
when I was an undergraduate and I I
really enjoyed it and I think that start
you know is a is a good writer
um interesting and it would benefit from
having you know that sort of
attentiveness uh paid to it but I don't
know I've kicked around some other ideas
talked about this with some some close
friends from time to time and
um
yeah that would that would be quite
interesting to to do
um
all right so I think I've got to scroll
back up here
um
the manual says thoughts on adorno's
negative dialectics if you're familiar
with it my first publication was
actually on adorno's negative dialectics
it's in an online Journal called Minerva
so you know I think adorno's in a really
interesting guy I find it difficult to
write on him in part because there's so
much going on in his works and if you
read adorno not in in English
translation but like in the original
German you really need five different
languages uh German French English Latin
Greek to be able to make out what what
he's saying I I realized that when I
started uh working on minimum auralia
for a a class that I was I was taking at
one time reading it in the the original
um
Barbara what made you pursue a PhD in
philosophy did you already intend on
becoming a professor at the time I heard
doctor titles in humanity are a risky
step
um so this is back in the 90s you know I
finished my undergraduate I majored in
philosophy and Mathematics
and I took a year off worked here in
Milwaukee where I'm living now back here
in my home town so to speak and uh
started applying to graduate schools I
had zero guidance from any of my
undergraduate professors didn't realize
that with my scores I pretty much could
have gone anywhere I wanted to but you
know like a lot of first generation
college students I didn't know how the
game was played and so I applied to
about 10 different schools
Marquette right down the road where I
teach uh from time to time immediately
lost my letters of recommendation uh
didn't bother to tell me until I was out
of the process so they they that was one
off the the books right there
of the other places I applied to
all of them accepted me
um but only three of them offered me
fellowships
and a fellowship is where you're
essentially paid to to do things and so
I had St Louis University Fordham
University and Southern Illinois
University at Carbondale St Louis and
Fordham each got to me with an offer
that was lower than Saint than uh
Southern Illinois University at
Carbondale
um and so I went there and I started out
in the master's program and then after I
finished my Master's I was like well
yeah may as well go on and do the PHD
there wasn't a lot of thought put into
it I enjoyed studying I was already used
to living poor so you know living on a
stipend that allowed me to buy books and
have some you know beer and cook for
myself and live in a little trailer
with eventually my my cats and stuff was
A-Okay by me
um did I think I would teach philosophy
I thought there was a chance I would do
that but I you know hiring back then was
the job market back then was crap it's
worse now but it was it was pretty bad
in the early 2000s you know and I I you
know I ended up doing a different thing
I my mom died I had an inheritance I
moved my family onto my family's land in
Indiana and applied for jobs around
there and wound up working in a Maximum
Security Prison for six years so
all right
um
let's see here
Joseph I have to stop and recognize you
do the that you're recognize that you're
undertaking in this project is amazing
well thanks yeah I mean it's taken a lot
of work a lot of time and I think if I
knew exactly how much work it would be
um maybe I wouldn't have committed to it
the way I did but fortunately I did and
it all worked out in the end you know
um Snoopy what do you feel are the most
interesting developments in contemporary
philosophy happening now I mean to me
the most interesting stuff is good
history of philosophy that connects it
up with the way that we live in the
present I'm not so interested in
contemporary analytic philosophy and
actually not all that interested in
contemporary Continental philosophy
because I find a lot of it
is a waste of my time you know
um
a lot of again Reinventing of wheels in
part because people don't read enough
before they start you know getting into
their their own things and you can't say
that about history of philosophy so much
um
boy Chef what do you think of the kind
of analytic hegelianism that has gained
traction thanks to Scholars such as
Pippin and Brandon so Brandon is an
interesting guy he starts out as an
analytic but I'd say he's actually more
of a historian a philosophy at this
point
um
and that's because he he's attentive to
the texts I would say that the analytic
so this applies to analytic nietzsianism
ptolemism hegallianism pick whatever you
want it's usually garbage because they
don't read enough texts they don't pay a
close enough attention to
systematic thinkers and they wanted they
want to basically mine them for stuff
that they can incorporate into their own
approach but they're and I'm not going
to say this about Pippin and Brandon I'm
going to say this about a lot of
Analytics uh uh people doing you know
historical figures they're lazy they
don't actually want to read an awful lot
and that's a problem because you're not
going to understand you're not even
going to understand Descartes without
reading his Corpus right so
uh Matt Sherman why do you find kant's
other critiques more interesting than
his first because more interesting stuff
is happening there I mean the
epistemology oh the copernican turn oh
wow so important yeah okay sure but not
that important because we can see that
there's lots of ways to go that don't
take you through Kant he's not the you
know
um gatekeeper that he presents himself
as being that some people make him into
and I find moral philosophy and and the
stuff that's going on in this in the
third critique which is a weird wacky
ride more interesting than kant's you
know
uh kind of forced epistemology and
you know kind of kind of boring
metaphysics
um I think we're Kant is most
interesting in the critique is where
he's talking about other philosophers at
first critique uh the second critique is
just amazing it's much shorter and if
you pair it together with the groundwork
and the the two parts of the metaphysics
and morals and uh religion within the
limits of reason alone which is
essentially an Ethics book you get this
really interesting uh understanding not
just of Ethics but you get a
philosophical anthropology out of it as
well that has to do with freedom so yeah
all right so more congratulations
um
ground floor Guthrie has caught the
first European philosopher to seriously
examine Eastern thinkers as far as I
know Khan doesn't actually examine
Eastern thinkers you might be thinking
of schopenhauer who is coming after Kant
who's very engaged with them
um but no Montesquieu has his Persian
letters you know there's engagements
with with non-western thought happening
uh in the 18th century
um so you know conch is not the the
first
um
George McLean it'd be good to give us a
flyover of the transition of thought
from con to Hagel to Heidegger
yeah I I that's that's not a compelling
project for me maybe somebody else could
do that
uh prox Productions blondells French
does seem significantly more complicated
than many of his contemporaries yeah
yeah sometimes sometimes not I mean I
would say that when you read say
somebody like marilopanti his prose is
pretty intricate and complex as well I
mean he's a little bit later right than
than blown down he also mentions blown
down but there's there's other French
thinkers
blondel's work sort of like Hegel
Blondell is not a great stylist he tries
to pack too much into
uh paragraph long sentences from time to
time
um his work is often described as turgid
but there's a lot of cool stuff
happening in it and you know you just
put in the work to figure out what the
hell the guy's saying and it's not
insurmountable you know
um it's just you know he's not like a a
wonderful stylist
like some of the other people are but I
mean you could take blown Dell and put
them up against writers French writers
post-war where French writing took this
very precious turn you know with the uh
people like for example Duluth and lakai
you know
um Dairy dust especially and you could
be like well you know
you could figure out what the hell
buried I was saying but it takes more
work than figuring out what Blondell is
saying
uh Joseph AGS was German idealism
influenced by medieval mysticism yeah
sure to some degree
um but these are like you're talking in
terms of huge abstractions what you
really would want to do more is say is
this German idealist influenced by
medieval Mystics and if so by which ones
you know by by Meister Eckhart
yakabuma you know you want to look for
who's talking about who or who's
invoking
uh which thinkers right
um all right oops just skipped a little
bit Villa is there any opinion on uh
Martin hagland I don't know who Martin
hagland is unfortunately so Elliot if
you're taking requests I'm not taking
requests uh what about habermas Harbor
Moss is an interesting guy and I I teach
his work sometimes and I think if I was
going to
uh do one of his works
I mean I I though the work of him that I
actually like the best is the structural
transformation of the public sphere but
that's sort of like a rents
um origins of totalitarianism is a very
dense historical work and I don't know
that I would be a good person for for
doing that
but you know his his book on um
that I've used in classes I'm blanking
on the title to like commutative
communicative
um what is it something something action
uh I mean that would be a good one to do
so but
I don't think I would do this series I
think I could do that in terms of uh
core concept videos instead right
um
all right let's see
Kun
Anna pora manka that's all of it if
you're if you're talking about the half
hour Hegel series uh yeah that's that's
all of it we've finished the entire
book which is awesome uh because now
there's about 375 I think videos out
there
um going through the text so like if
you're you know you're reading and
you're like I can't figure out what the
hell paragraph 351 is saying well you
can Google Hegel
phenomenology 351 and you'll you'll find
the video for it that'll help you out
you know
um
let's see
Lotus van who else is excited for the
Hegel Cameo before the Battle of Vienna
and the Napoleon movie this year is is
there actually a Hegel cameo in there I
don't know that there is uh I don't
watch a lot of historical movies because
they tend to be crap
um and I don't you know I don't like to
waste my time on stuff that's more more
Glitz than actual content and that's
what Hollywood
um
Hollywood historical movies tend to be
so I don't know
uh Masa Milano any thoughts on
non-philosophy of the rule haven't read
them and or the so-called speculative
realism movement I think we're going to
look back on the speculative realism
movement and say well that was a cool
fad
um didn't really
you know where it was doing something
interesting
a lot of times it was kind of like
rehashing older stuff
um I I don't think there is a lot of
uh ballast so to speak in that that ship
and that's fine there's lots of
philosophical movements like that when
you know the history of philosophy you
see people that are like this is the
next big thing and
10 years later everyone's like what was
that again I forgot about that and maybe
sometimes it'll come back but I just
haven't found
the stuff that I've you know admittedly
I haven't like gone deep into their
attacks but I've met Grand Harmon you
know and wasn't super impressed
um
so I you know
it's one of those things I'm probably
not going to spend much more time on
because I got other stuff to do
um Alfonso says I recently discovered
half our Hegel videos already watched
through episodes my God Hagel is really
different from anything I've seen yeah I
mean the common reaction to opening up
the the
um
the preface is like what in the hell is
this you know
um so it's quite understandable that was
one of my motives for doing the the
video series
uh that's that's totally understandable
um
all right
a lot of people writing Hegel Hegel
Hegel
um
Barbara says is the philosophy of
Consciousness that is pan psychism
something that interests you philosophy
of Consciousness is very interesting to
me I mean
that's this right uh pan psychism not
very interesting to me and there is much
more discussion of Consciousness than
just by Pan psychists
um so sure I mean we're all conscious
right and we're all involved in that and
people you know philosophers been
thinking about that as well as other
sciences that came out of philosophy
like psychology for millennia
um
Andy says do you have a current favorite
Eastern thinker I try to avoid Eastern
as a designation I'd rather talk about
like the East Asian cultural sphere
which is different than the South Asian
cultural sphere which is different than
the uh Islamic cultural sphere and all
of them eventually interpenetrate each
other and contribute to each other as
well as to the West
um do I have a favorite thinker
I wouldn't say so I mean I don't have a
favorite Western thinker so any more
than I actually have a favorite band
um
so
no I mean I I will say this too that I
you know occasionally teach some
non-western thinkers but and a lot of
people like make requests or sometimes
demands that I should I should be much
more you know Global and stuff like that
and my answer is well you know
I can read
um five languages one I was born into
and the other I was kind of half-assed
born into that's French because my
mother's family is French Canadian
um so I can read you know French English
German uh ancient Greek and Latin but I
don't read classical Chinese you know
I've made some efforts to learn uh
Mandarin but never got very far I don't
read any of the South Asian you know uh
languages like Sanskrit or poly or you
know those sorts of things so I'm I'm
more leery of doing content uh stuff
where I don't I don't have any prospects
for checking the translations you can
say Well why'd you do stuff on
Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard then it's a
little bit closer and I can be
reasonably confident of the translations
and I try not to make much you know rest
on them the translations so
yeah all right Anthony Summers with more
subscribers or patreon supporters with
releasing a PDF with the initial points
you put on the board be something to
assist the learning not something to
replace the video you know I considered
that but I think after almost a decade
it's time for the half hour Hegel
project to come to a close
um I've thought about you know putting
together going through the videos and
like you know seeing what I actually put
on the chalkboard and turning that into
like um like you said PDFs
um that's a possibility maybe down the
line
um
but I mean
you know there'd have to be some support
for it because that takes a good bit of
time
um and I think what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna
consolidate all my Patriot into just the
one big patreon account
and um I got to go through and like you
know make the page look better do a lot
of tidying up anyway and reorganizing
with my online presence so yeah that may
happen uh will says thank you for
helping people think yeah that's cool
uh Ken says it'd be fascinating to see a
deeper dive into some Russian
philosophers such as shastoff and
plecanov
I definitely want to do more right
um I've only done much work on
um one of his is quite early
books I think that Athens and Jerusalem
would be ripe for that's like is is more
or less latest workout by the way also a
contribution to the 1930s Christian
philosophy debates it was originally
published in Parts in the review to MIDI
physique morale and then put into a book
and it's probably his most popular book
um
so I've done stuff on all things are
possible and I need to do some more on
that some more con core concept videos
um he's got a really cool book on
Dostoevsky and Nietzsche that's a little
bit earlier by the way along with the
Danish uh literary critic York brondes
is one of the first people to see these
interconnections between Nietzsche
Dostoyevsky uh now Chef stuff doesn't
realize Kierkegaard but he finds that
later on it's wholestoy and Chekhov
um
and you know to be able to notice those
those sort of connections I think is
really cool so
uh all right let's see it just skipped a
little bit
um
oh here's an interesting question
acrb any opinions on the relatively
recent karnap Resurgence or karnaps work
generally
yeah it was so I was really surprised by
that right that people are now into
karnat but I mean we see this happen for
a long time like nobody was reading
barracks on other than you know people
like to lose and now there's like lots
of interest in in barrettson and you're
like where did this come from or
shopping another great example when I
was in graduate school
the attitude of a lot of the professors
is well you read schopenhauer so you can
understand nature better he's basically
just a footnote to meet you not really
worth reading
in his own right and there were people
toiling away doing work on schopenhauer
like Wolfgang shermacher who later on
down the line I got to take a graduate
level class with at European graduate
school when I was a visiting scholar
there
and uh
you know like 10 years ago people
started asking when are you gonna do
videos on Chopin now I'm interested in
schopenhower and I was like really how'd
that happen so with karnap yeah you're
like holy crap how did people get
interested in this guy again and I think
it's cool that people are because he's
an interesting guy right
um
tarkovsky will this be uploaded later
it's being uploaded right now there's a
YouTube live and so you know this is a
uh a video that you can see on my
channel you just gotta go to the live
section
uh app and Jafar legendary moment I love
the series very ambitious project so
cool it's complete yeah it is it's great
that it's complete
um I had some worries at some point you
know whether I would actually manage to
to get it done and how long was it gonna
take me
um but you know you just keep plugging
away at it and eventually you know you
get to the end of of a book I guess I'm
lucky I didn't pick a book that's even
longer than the phenomenology of spirit
um but it's it's pretty long as it is
all right saxophone snowman I followed
your series while reading Hegel and
danish that's that's interesting that's
got to be uh quite a translation
so yeah
um
by the way that guy that I mentioned
just a little bit ago Garrett Brandeis
Danish
um really interesting thinker he is the
one who turned Nietzsche on to
Dostoyevsky he wrote Nature and he's
like
this guy you know you should check him
out and Nietzsche read what's actually
my favorite work by Dostoevsky which is
translated either as the demons or the
uh possessed really great work
um peaches what is a German idealist
pickup line hey look I got to get your
number
um
yeah I don't know uh
uh we could do all sorts of word play I
suppose you know
on ficta make it into like
fitting or fit and what would we do with
shelling or schopenhauer
um I I don't really know it's a good
question
um
let's see
any thoughts on sellers uh
no not really I don't I don't spend time
reading uh sellers uh Zeitgeist do some
videos on sun Zoom I mean why would I I
just told you exactly why I don't do
videos on on Chinese philosophy uh and
if I was gonna do it why would I do it
on Sun Tzu rather than you know
Confucius or um without a jing or
drungzza or somebody who's you know more
in the area of philosophy Jack have you
read much Daria I almost wrote my
dissertation on Buried
um and I've actually published on Buried
uh so yeah I've read a bit of him
um
Barbara you mentioned you're more
inclined towards non-contemporary
philosophers is there any current
philosophy you fancy who's reading you
could recommend well there's many of
them Aleister McIntyre right who I've
actually studied with he's he's still
alive a lot of these great historians
like Julia Annas and uh Margaret Graver
and Christopher Gill who's a friend and
colleague of mine John Sellers who's a
younger friend and colleague of mine
closer to my own age Anthony long
um you know lots and lots of people in
the
um doing great work in philosophy as a
way of life and the history of
philosophy or as McIntyre puts a
tradition guided inquiry Robert Audi is
still alive and out there and still
contributing to the field you know I
just did some videos actually I'm still
in the process of releasing videos on
him so yeah there's tons of people who
are contemporary who I find interesting
and you should understand that
contemporary philosophy when we say
contemporary that goes all the way back
to like the 1950s
so you know
what I'm teaching at at Marquette and
I'm teaching uh my my foundations class
it's supposed to have a contemporary
philosopher in it I count Simone de
bouvoir as my contemporary philosopher
for that so
um Alfonso thoughts on Marxism how do
you see hegelian dialectics on
historical materialism I think that
hegelian dialectics the real stuff that
you actually find in this is very
different than the thesis antithesis
synthesis
um weirdness that that people work with
and the Marxist seem to be mostly into
that
rather than actually drawing on hegel's
dialectics and that's fine because
dialectics is an equivocal term Plato
has dialectics Aristotle has dialectics
the stoics had dialectics you know it
doesn't always mean exactly the same
thing thoughts about Marxism like I said
a little bit earlier the marxists are
kind of a hot mess they're not really a
community there's probably nothing a
Marxist hates more than a fellow Marxist
that has a slightly different point of
view than them on Marx or Hagel or pick
pick whatever interpreter of marks that
you want so now that said I think that
there are some contributions that Marx
has made
um I just don't I don't you know
appropriate him as a systematic thinker
who has the answers to everything you
should also remember too that Marx was
sort of like George Washington very very
very good at getting Rivals put out of
commission you know Rivals who you
should have probably collaborated with
so
uh Jay Lynch I'm a current philosophy
undergrad just want to say your videos
are fantastic thank you so much for your
hard work oh you're very welcome I'm
glad that they've been helpful for you
um
Zeitgeist Hagel and schopenhauer should
have collapsed well they kind of did
yeah at least Hegel helped to get Chopin
power if I remember the story right his
his job and then schopenhauer returned
the favor by trying to schedule his
classes at the same time as hegel's
fighting that you know nobody really
wanted to go to his classes that meant a
significant reduction in his income and
he says all sorts of nasty things about
Hegel uh it's clear that schopenhauer
couldn't have collaborated with Hegel
um and you know given the shitty things
that that schopenhauer said about Diego
I don't know why Hagel would have wanted
to collaborate with him
um
Jordan what do you think about the
introduction to the phenomenology like
finding the criteria philosophy of
Consciousness in terms of Consciousness
I think the introduction is a lot easier
to read than the preface right and I
think I may have mentioned that at the
very beginning of the uh set of videos
on the introduction I mean hegel's you
know the the preface is this all this
stuff all kind of jumbled together
it's almost like listening to somebody
do free association with things that
they're really into and have thought
about for a long time the introduction
is a bit more straightforward and
thinking about the issues of where are
we in philosophy now and how do we avoid
skepticism and how do we incorporate
things
um
all right uh
just skipped a bit here
uh Josh did the French 1930s Christian
debate Christian philosophy debates he
made an impact Vatican to it all
[Music]
um indirectly I mean Maurice Blondell
has been called by Xavier Ryan the
philosopher of Vatican II he's also the
philosopher of John Paul II fide razio
as fiaker long has has argued I think
quite successfully in an article on it
um he's not mentioned in fide razio and
the reason is because the entire
document is blondely and in its uh
approach
by the way Carol votilla who becomes
John Paul II
new blown out quite well because he
writes about him in his great work the
acting person so you know thinkers who
were involved in those Christian
philosophy debates play a role in in
Vatican too their thought influences
other people
so yeah there's there's some impact you
could say uh Chase working through the
phenomenology for the first time your
lessons are indispensable achievement
I'm glad that's that's helpful uh
sacrifice Zone a podcast do you have any
favorite Fiction with philosophical
content Samuel Delaney has a short story
when an old woman tries to explain
dialectics to one of the village
children
well you are if you don't know about it
you are in for a treat I have an entire
series called worlds of speculative
fiction where I look at World building
and philosophical themes we are now in
what year eight of the series it was a
monthly series that I was doing at a
local library and I've been doing it
online we just did Thomas legati
um so there's 73 different episodes that
you can watch if you'd like to they're
all at least an hour and 20 minutes long
I've also done a lot of Core Concepts on
philosophical fiction including
um
Theodore Dostoevsky
um some other thinkers as well I've got
an entire series called speculative
fiction studies where I've you know
looked at uh Ursula K Le Guin gone
through the entire Earthsea uh Saga
um a bit of Philip Jose farmer to Philip
K dick books a man in the High Castle
which I think I did 19 videos on and
um
oh Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep
so yeah I've I've done some I've got
some favorite Fiction with philosophical
content
uh equations keep plugging away at it me
in 50 years when I'm halfway through the
book I won't take you that long just
just keep reading and you'll you'll do
okay with it
uh Jamie what are your thoughts on
g-shek's reading of Hegel I basically
ignore zizak at this point he was he was
quite rigorous and interesting in his
early work uh I encountered him first in
the 1990s I saw his work become
progressively more and more let's just
say speculative and and uh less about
you know rigorous uh backing up of
claims and more like free association I
don't I don't really take him that
seriously at this point in time so and
so Zeitgeist a half hour zizak would be
so fire ain't gonna happen for me
because I'm not interested in zizak
really
uh canara do you agree with Todd
McGowan's notion Hegel can be read as a
proto-psychoanalytic theorist stuck
using German idealist vocabulary
can sure you can read them however you
want to
should I mean that's not the reading I
would pick but you know McGowan like so
many other interpreters has got his
shtick and he's gonna stick with it and
elaborate it and do whatever he can with
it but I don't find that particularly uh
interesting or attractive right
[Music]
um
let's see here
now you see I think your series might be
the longest non-gaming series on YouTube
maybe I don't know I mean
there's probably longer series out there
that we just haven't like come across
uh Jordan what do you think of the what
do you first think of the force and
understanding when you first read
through it oh the first time I read
through it I I actually was reading it
in German because I had this uh second
edition of the phenomenology that I
found in our University library and you
know first in the understanding is a
hell of a lot more difficult than the
two preceding sections and I was like
what in the hell you know like I said
um and then you know we talked about it
in class uh my professor was mostly
interested in the concept of force not
quite so interested in the world stuff
going on there
um book pill says uh worlds of
speculative fiction is some of the very
best sci-fi fantasy content on YouTube
oh thank you that's that's very nice I'm
glad that you enjoy it uh Lauren do you
ever plan on covering some adorno texts
uh you know if I was gonna do it I
probably would do instead of adorno
himself I'd probably do a Dorner on a
horchheimer's dialectic of enlightenment
which I think is is pretty readable
um but I don't know I it's not a high
priority for me
um
let's see here
oh Jordan do you think that the
phenomenology is a necessary stepping
point if you want to understand the
science of logic so that's a great
question
and you know I would say no
um
and there's a lot of people as I
mentioned earlier who want to see a very
strong correlation between the
phenomenology and the science of logic
it appears that Hagel himself
thought that there was and you know it's
his own writings right but exactly what
the correlations are
higgle Scholars don't agree on that and
I think the two Works can be read
separately
and you can get a lot out of it I I
don't like buy into the hegelian system
or that like you have to understand the
entire system or you can't understand
any part of it I think you can take bits
and pieces and and use them outside of
their contacts for productive purposes
like you could take the section on the
syllogisms and get something out of that
from the science of logic that that's
quite interesting
uh Bartholomew when did you first start
reading Hegel as an undergrad no as an
undergrad uh Hegel was despised by my
two professors
um and I didn't read them until I got to
graduate school unfortunately by then I
had enough German that I could you know
use the English and the German text
actually I also read hip Elites French
uh translation as well which is really
great because there's like all these
footnotes and stuff like that so
um Josh do you agree with McIntyre's
conclusion and after virtue we must
either return to the Aristotelian
discourse concerning morality or Embrace
niche's view in the genealogy of morals
that's not what McIntyre actually says
um McIntyre himself has you know after
virtue is one of the four book series
and it's only the first book you want to
also read who's Justice which
rationality three rival versions and
pennant rational animals to get the
Fuller picture and you know to answer
your question a little facetiously not
even McIntyre thinks that by the time
that we get to dependent rational
animals so
um
Matt Sherman did you find anything
specifically valuable in the early more
rigorous gizek
yeah rigorous discussions of what's
going on in lacah for example
um but it's been a long time since I've
read that
um
all right
prague's Productions the hegel's ideas
of any relationship to the common
categories found in neoplatonic thinkers
and is it worthwhile to see Hegel
especially the philosophy of history in
these categories it is not worth it at
all and uh the neoplatonists don't agree
on on you know what the categories are
anyway they're the neoplatenness are not
a unified school
they're kind of a loose connection of it
really interesting thinkers but
um there's a lot of different versions
of neoplatonism out there and uh I I
would say you want to be kind of careful
about saying that there's a you know
neoplatonist thing
um
relative is what languages do you speak
basically just French and English I mean
German I can get by with if I've been in
country for a while it takes me a while
now as an older person to get my ear
tuned I'm also a little bit deaf
due to tinnitus
is that the way it's pronounced
um so that also makes like French a
little bit tricky for me or sometimes
even when people are speaking English
you know uh French has all sorts of what
they tell your assignment letters that
aren't actually completely silent
um so you know I mostly use English but
if need be I can get by with French and
you know I mean I can
do a little bit of Portuguese but not
much it all depends on what I'm using at
the time and obviously I don't speak
Latin or Greek you know
um
Zachary have you ever taught graduate
philosophy seminars would you be
interested in teaching grad philosophy
seminars at some point I'd be interested
if anybody would actually have me do it
but I've never had the opportunity to to
do that and um
graduate stuff is easier to teach than
undergraduate because they're go-getters
you know you just get steer them towards
the material you make them do
presentations in class the hardest class
is to teach are actually intro to
philosophy ethics these lower level
classes for non-majors they're the most
challenging and that's where you become
a good teacher teaching those kinds of
things but sure if we have somebody
wanted to hire me to teach grad classes
I don't see that happening anytime soon
so Jordan do you think that the stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy Consciousness
is a refutation of solipsism like Pfizer
does I don't know who bizer is and that
I mean I don't think it's a refutation
of solipsism
um and that's a really weird point of
view to take like totally almost like
totally off topic it's sort of like
going into an art museum and being like
I love these cracks in the floor you
know and not looking at the art
um
Lauren says a little off topic do you
know about Bernard Suzanne's reading
order for Plato have you tried the order
do you find it valuable considering
other orderings aren't popular today I
know about it but I consider it
there's no reason why we should take it
on any more than we have to do the
ordering and that we find in um middle
platonism or later neoplatonism you read
the text however you want to you know
and you don't need somebody else bossing
you around in the back of your head
telling you this is the way to do it you
know you will get the most out of it
this way
I mean I didn't read Plato in any sort
of order you know and uh hopefully I
kind of know what I'm talking about when
I'm
presenting Adam right
um
let's see here
that said podcast have you heard of the
work of Joseph Rouse never even heard of
Joseph Rouse so nope but don't take that
as you know something bad against him
because there's literally tens of
thousands of authors that I haven't
heard of who might be interesting but
you know we get 24 hours a day and I
spend most of that reading people who
I've already read and then occasionally
branching out into others
um Stan canner thoughts on John
McDowell's work don't have any thoughts
on John McDowell's work really
um lucky RG are there any interesting
connections you can think of between
hegel's ideas
uh especially in the phenomenology in
the early church fathers
no I don't see any really interesting
ideas between them
um or connections between them
um Alexandra have you delved into the
science of logic yeah I've read the
whole science of logic when I mentioned
at the beginning when I did my special
thinkers
uh exam on Hegel as a PhD student I had
to like study sections and be able to
talk about them competently in exams of
the science of logic and the entirety of
the phenomenology
um
Bengal Studio do you think Hegel is
relevant to artificial intelligence not
directly but in in some ways you know
you can adapt some of the things that
he's saying about Consciousness and you
know like the difference between
representational thinking or philosophy
the understanding as he calls it later
and the
um lectures on the lectures on the
philosophy of religion and conceptual
thinking artificial intelligence at this
point is just a metaphor it's not
actually intelligent it's parasitic on
human intelligence
um but you know there could be something
like that in the future
um
let's see here Josh what do you think of
this statement from foucaultan Hegel we
have to determine the extent to which
our anti-hegalianism is one of his
tricks yeah I think that's just typical
like Foucault bullshitting around
basically
um Bartholomew have you done a video on
Plato's per amenities you can always
find What I've Done videos on by just
searching you know uh any anything I've
actually done a video on will come up I
haven't done it anything on that
um do you find a lot of value in that
dialogue I don't find a lot of value in
the dialectic portion of it which is the
main part but the criticism of the
doctrine forms you know pretty important
isn't it my analytic Professor told me
it's jibber jabber yeah okay I mean
different different folks have different
points of view right
um
Jordan do you think that hegel's being
nothing becoming dialectic can be read
into Plato's permanentes I mean you can
read anything into whatever you want to
it's just whether there's an actual
productive you know reading that comes
out of that
um
let's see
one zero three two one able starting on
the Hegel Journey with you thank you for
all of this I have some minor background
in philosophy but never read Kant
reading is prologomina be sufficient to
get caught up for Hegel can't hurt I
mean
you probably also want to read the
groundwork if you're going to do that
um it's not like Hegel is you know a
conscient
um he's doing his own thing
um You probably would want to read just
as much of aristobal as you would want
of a Kant I suppose
um
yeah
let's see Lauren Kyo is there any lesser
known philosophers you think would be
worth looking into if I wanted to study
dialectics as a general concept there's
no General concept of dialectics there's
a whole bunch of different Notions of
dialectics so I don't really have
recommendations on that
um
Oliver what's your opinion on kojev's
reading of Hegel I mentioned that
already some say completely misread
Hegel
um yeah people say lots of stuff it
doesn't mean that it's actually true or
even intelligent completely misread
angle I mean how the hell would you
completely misread Hagel I guess turning
him into a coffee cup or something is
that is that what kojev did uh nobody
completely misreads the The Thinker
um kojav is doing his own schnick and
he's kind of using Hegel for what he he
wants to you know
um Gavin on the topic of AI have you
experimented with using chat GPT I've
published some pieces on that over you
know recent months so yeah I've
experimented with it
um
relativist do you agree with nature
about genealogy of morality Nietzsche
wrote the genealogy of morality
genealogy of morality is not a thing
that you can agree with Nietzsche on
because it's not a
thesis so I I I'm not sure what you're
asking Clays Philip thanks for
everything you do extremely useful if
you read Heidegger's what is called
thinking I've just finished it really
made me think about the nature thinking
yeah I've read it it's good
um I I you know
I usually introduce people to Heidegger
by using what is metaphysics Heidegger
has a lot of what is XYZ right stuff
that he does
um
so yeah High Acres Heidegger's Fun by
the way Heidegger has a great little
book on Hegel unfortunately he only goes
up to the self-consciousness section but
Heidegger actually talks about Hegel
quite a few times in his Works he thinks
of Hegel as a very important
metaphysician uh transforming the way in
which we understand being right
um Roman weingartner uh in light of that
previous question about Plato and Hegel
being able to work together what do you
think about the productivity of creative
readings I don't know what creative
readings are so
I don't know
um
all right uh Jordan what do you think of
kierkegaard's critiques of Hegel are
they devastating for his project
absolutely not
um Kierkegaard doesn't have critiques of
Hagley as criticisms of Hegel a critique
is a larger project that you'd be doing
and just as with like hegel's criticism
of uh stoicism you always actually have
to go to the thing that's being
criticized and see whether the criticism
is on point and sometimes Kierkegaard is
and sometimes he isn't you know uh Pagel
gets stoicism wrong
um it could apply to certain people that
are like fake stoics in the present or
in his time
um but you know same thing with like
Nietzsche and Beyond Good and Evil you
know he uh he's got that passage early
on that everybody reads and then they
don't read the other passages where he
like says we stoics
um
you know you have to figure out like
what is a good criticism and what's kind
of off base a lot of the criticisms that
Kierkegaard is making of Hegel Hegel is
really a stand-in for hegelianism and
the hegelianism of of Denmark at the
time seemed to be pretty you know pretty
low-grade philosophy
um
all right
um knowing what you know now would you
fundamentally change anything about the
way you taught the early chapters
classes on phenomenology 10 years ago so
I didn't teach and they're not classes
they are commentary videos right
um better understood is sort of like
parts of uh extended book I'm not
teaching a class when I'm teaching a
class there's homework there's you know
all sorts of other stuff that's involved
in that like you know a an actual class
management system
um and you know the only thing that I
would change is use a better camera and
use a lapel mic otherwise no I'd I'd
stick by that stuff you know
um now every once in a while people will
be like hey you know in this video from
eight years ago you said XYZ and I'll be
like I mean I said a lot of stuff
if there's 375 videos
then there is so 150 plus uh 35s 185. so
you know about
187 hours of content I don't always
remember every single thing that I said
right so
um Clay is Philip have you considered
doing something on the exegesis of
Philip K dick that would be fun if
you've ever read the eggs of Jesus you
know it's not a book that you would do
uh some sort of videos on because it's
it's a mishmash it's all sorts of like
notes that he's taking he's rambling all
over the place I have actually brought
it up in my uh worlds of speculative
fiction
um sessions on Philip K dick so if you
go to those you'll see me you know when
we're talking about
um for example the difference between
Androids and humans and why that matters
he's got some passages in the exegesis
where that's that's important right and
I'll bring it in there but I don't think
I'll ever do videos specifically just on
the exegesis
um because it's you know it's this thick
right so I think it's that's one of
those books you know I've done this
video on books with aura where
um
people like to talk about them but very
few people have actually read them
entirely
um so I think the exit Jesus is like
that
uh let's see here
Roman says to clarify creative as in
like a more broad less historically
rigorous interpretation or a reading
that's suggestive of what the writer
wants to achieve
well I mean some of those readings are
good and some of those are crap a lot of
times people engage in Ace ages rather
than exegesis uh projecting what it is
that they want to find in the text in
the text and I don't I don't find those
particularly interesting or useful
because I want to if I'm going to read
secondary literature I want to learn
something about what the person is
talking about right
um
now that said there are some thinkers
whose secondary lit is effectively what
you're calling these creative
interpretations that are quite
interesting I mean to lose on the
history of philosophy you're always
getting more to lose than you are the
people that he's talking about but it
you know it's it's kind of cool his
Nietzsche book his uh leibniz book you
know logic of sense uh that's all fun
stuff Heidegger does that all the time
and I find his stuff kind of interesting
as well so
all right
um
let's see
Gavin asked what other books come to
your mind you'd classify as books of War
I did a whole video on that so you can
easily look that up uh September what
music have you been listening to lately
I mean today I started the morning
listening to some uh uh Judas Priest and
some uh
uh tank some Motorhead some uh deep
purple and my favorite Black Sabbath
song Zero the Hero
um
so you know mostly listen to metal
um by the way Scott truly and I are
starting classic metal class back up
again in November our schedules are now
able to allow this he's been doing a lot
of gigging lately so he hasn't had much
time for for that but as the season
comes to a bit of a close you'll have a
bit more time and uh we're gonna resume
that with uh some discussions about
ethical dimensions of how certain bands
structure their concerts
um
all right
let's see here Chase says the Kyoto
school that interesting engagements with
German thought Hagel and Heidegger yeah
lots of people did I mean the Kyoto
school is interesting Jim Beau would you
ever cover zizak I've already talked
about that earlier in this this session
g-jack could be very very low on my list
I mean I guess you could say I cover him
every time that people ask me questions
about g-jack don't I you know I
basically have to say the same thing
over and over again that he
uh you know was rigorous in his early
stuff which was quite interesting and
now he's just kind of like shooting from
the hip all the time
um
all right
um so I'm gonna go out on this question
because it's already 1 30 and I've got
another event coming up for uh the
patreon supporters of the project a
little bit more intimate celebration a
little bit later on today mohis Muhammad
do you do journaling if you find utility
in it I do not and I have not found
journaling helpful for me
um lots of people get lots of benefit
out of it and I'm kind of an outlier so
I don't say that people shouldn't
Journal because I don't find it useful I
just find other things more useful for
me like just reading the text and
thinking about them and applying them in
my My Life
um but you know I do writing
non-creative non-fiction stuff where I
like remember things but yeah I don't do
like daily journaling I get that a lot
of other people enjoy that
um
I've tried it i i find I rarely go back
to the stuff that I write in that way
and I don't get that many insights out
of it unfortunately so
like being tone deaf I suppose right all
right so uh I am going to uh say good
you know good evening good night good
afternoon good morning to you wherever
you are in the world I'm glad all of you
could join me for this uh little
celebration and Q a and uh you know
we've got cool stuff coming up it won't
be all necessarily Hegel related
although I you know I kind of want to do
some Court more core concept videos on
Hegel down the line as well but the next
big project which I I'll be starting in
November not not in October because I've
got so much going on in October we'll be
applying this methodology to
um
Saint Anselm's pros logian and then you
know that'll probably take a little
while uh and then I'll be doing it with
Renee Descartes the meditations on first
philosophy which is a wonderful work and
then we'll see about what big book I
ought to do maybe I'll put a vote out
there in social media down the line so
you know you might probably want to
follow me uh if you're not already in
YouTube getting you know using the uh
notifications thing maybe in Twitter if
Twitter stays around or Facebook or the
other things that I use so all right uh
by the way I'll close this by saying
thanks to everybody who's been
supporting this project this entire time
um you know it's uh it's a lot of work
and
um
it's been very helpful to have people
who were encouraging about it who said
that they get some value from it so all
right that's enough I will see all of
you uh down the line and we'll do some
uh some other philosophers with the same
sort of methodology